euh j'ai mis une photo de mes fesses
dans le diapo d'un cours de science ça
ça doit être toi tu es exhibitionniste
pas moi je vous raconterai mais ce n'est
pas
au barco puisque je suis animateur pour
l'instant jusqu'à 20h20 l'heure à
laquelle nous rejoindre non ce n'est pas
bon
non alors Jean-Michel maire moi alors
non ce serait pas répéter son son boule
en fait c'était en 5e c'était avec
Madame février ma prof de SVT février
et donc pour me venger j'ai pris une
photo de mes fesses et j'ai mis le
négatif dans le rétroprojecteur elle a
arrêté le cours elle a dit je ne
reprends pas le tour tant que je ne sais
pas qui est ce cul et donc est-ce que
vous êtes dénoncé je me suis dénoncé
ouais devant mes amis c'était très
difficile
et qu'est-ce que vous a fait ah bah rien
j'étais puni j'ai fait j'ai eu des
heures de colle ça va ça va c'était
voilà ça passe ça passe février ah j'ai
simulé un malaise pour éviter un
contrôle alors ça aurait pu être gagné
le Moro Delphine ça c'est le genre de
Bernard
très bien alors non c'était un contrôle
de sciences Nath je me souviens j'avais
pas j'avais pas du tout révisé et
c'était sur la mitose la myose et tout
ça
non c'est le renouvellement
avec des problèmes avec des problèmes
gynécologiques ça n'a rien à voir
d'accord
j'avais dit que je me sentais mal donc
je suis allée à l'infirmerie et comme ça
j'ai pas eu de mauvaise note c'est pas
c'est pas ouf
j'étais une polar en fait je travaillais
très bien enfin je travaillais beaucoup
assidûment et j'étais pas talentueux
laborieuse exactement
et vous avez votre bac oui quand même
avec une mention aussi la mention assez
bien mention Bien ah oui
ah oui quand même
tout le monde a le bac vous répond non
pas moi
j'ai pas voulu y aller moi Daniel Bossi
vous l'avez le bac oui tout le monde
avec moi
c'est beaucoup plus dur à notre époque
maintenant le bac directement bah oui
c'est compliqué niveau est-ce que Gilles
mais c'est bien
ce métier huissier de justice
je tiens à la télé d'une main et le
réfrigérateur
c'est un métier éminemment responsable
comme tous les métiers j'ai exercé
pendant deux ans voilà l'image elle est
non il y a une image mais il y a une
image aussi quand on en a besoin
se protéger en même temps bon on les
bois mais on se porte quand même hein
ministériel vous savez qu'on n'est pas
par ministériel on est des officiers
vous avez encore une carte attends vous
avez une carte rigolo
alors mon prof m'a demandé de prendre la
porte j'ai littéralement pris la porte
donc oui personne l'a démonté elle est
partie avec la CG ça c'est drôle non ça
c'est drôle des muscles donc si c'est
drôle ça peut pas être Gilles Daniel
c'est pas une fille si c'est Gilles non
c'est pas moi
[Applaudissements]
j'étais le cauchemar des profs quand
j'étais dissipé tous les jours j'allais
au travail et je répétais pour TPMP quoi
j'étais c'était hallucine ah vous
répétiez en 1924 pour TPMP
mais j'avais fait un pari avec un copain
j'ai réussi à le faire et et à cette
époque là est-ce que vous démonter
d'autres choses que les portes toujours
pas non plus même au lycée même en
troisième
j'étais amoureuse de Jean le poulain
donc déjà
dans un lycée mix ou un mix quand même
donc il y avait des garçons ouais
c'est important de bien préciser les
choses et rien
de blues
on voit une cravate
les gens là une photo avantageuse très
bien
deux fois d'animaux
c'est plutôt sympa très bien écoutez
merci alors on va prendre notre petite
notre petite liste alors
alors ça alors je sais pas qui a fait ça
mais ça c'est un grand malade j'ai
laissé tomber deux vieilles grenades
dortoir de l'école alors si vraiment
cette anecdote est vrai ce sont des
vrais grenades je pense que c'est un
psychopathe
vous m'avez pas cité là
j'ai pas 50 c'est pas moi
c'est évident
[Musique]
déjà comment on fait pas exprès à
prendre des grenades avec soi pour aller
au lycée là on vit dans une autre époque
moi je suis né en 1960 c'était 60
c'était 15 ans après la fin de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale c'est-à-dire
qu'on se baladait dans les champs on
trouvait des armes j'habitais dans l'Est
dans les forêts vosgiennes on trouvait
le tout un arbre tombé il y avait des
caisses de Grenade etc et tous les
garçons de ma classe vous êtes tous
collection d'armes d'Imagine arriver en
cours Jean-Michel tu peux laisser
décalage des gosses s'il te plaît
[Applaudissements]
on faisait tous montrer ce qu'on avait
trouvé pendant le weekend on s'est
échangé les choses et moi j'avais
vraiment envie de grenades complètement
rouillé mais qui était peut-être encore
dangereuse mais il y a encore
aujourd'hui les accidents qui arrivent
dans les forêts avec des des obus
entériens qui pètent hein bien sûr
c'était n'importe quoi
voilà on est quand même bravo bravo ah
oui quand même ah oui
[Applaudissements]
nous aussi on trouvait des armes entre
des grenades des armes à l'époque c'est
vrai ah oui le prix de Bordeaux là où
j'ai vidé ah bah là où vous avez votre
maison non c'est un appartement HLM là
et c'était il y avait un lac à côté il y
avait même un temps que dedans et tout
tu penses bien que c'était notre grande
plaisir d'y aller et on ramassait des
des armes certes rouillé mais il y avait
des grenades effectivement des obus de
tout c'est incroyable
maintenant quand même pour aller enlever
tout ça
en fait on a une équipe de gangster ici
alors je m'amusais à coller les fesses
de mes camarades sur leur chaîne ça
c'est sympa je l'ai fait avec un super
glue ça c'est très sympa
de la boule puante
[Musique]
non mais c'est très con quoi ça a l'air
de rien tu sais on avait des des de la
colle fluide il y en avait une tu sais
qui sentait bon on se mettait dans le
nez là
ouais je sais pas elle sortait de la
santé
la marée tôt avec modération
ça pété on comprend comment je suis ça
et donc je m'amusais à verser mais
vraiment j'ai souvent fait à verser de
la colère alors liquide sur n'importe
quel siège de quelqu'un casser les pieds
un voyou
ça colle bien le principe de la colle
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous allez souligner dès qu'on dit un
truc un petit peu voilà ok pas de grand
intérêt à chaque fois mettre une petite
pipe
vous avez été viré pour ça ou pas non
parce que j'en ai jamais su que c'était
moi j'ai une gueule d'ange ah oui quand
j'étais petit en plus
bien sûr et si on punissait quelqu'un
d'autre
c'est un beau camarade hein
alors une fille a refusé de me prêter un
stylo pour me venger j'ai collé un
chewing-gum dans ses cheveux
ça c'est un truc de meuf ça c'est un
truc de fou c'est c'est où la brume
c'est où la brune ou la ruche c'est toi
comme
j'ai vécu 12 ans à Los Angeles et aussi
à New York
les deux quand vous étiez petit ou quand
vous étiez plus grands
[Rires]
en France voilà à Paris et donc voilà
j'étais en quête en tout cas vous faites
de super interviews
[Applaudissements]
est américaine mais en fait elle est
américaine de papa qu'elle a étudié en
France elle est née là-bas
donc vous allez coller un chewing-gum
dans les cheveux
du prof et un jour je vais j'avais rien
je lui ai demandé un stylo elle a refusé
et comme vous savez tout ce que j'adore
les gens désagréables voilà oups je ne
vois pas du tout
non
des gens qui pensent que c'est des
cheveux des faux cheveux ou des cheveux
de pelle c'est mes cheveux qu'on a
déplacés
vos cheveux bah oui c'est mes cheveux
qu'on a pu passer de derrière
des fesses
alors
une bonne fois pour toute
l'intégralité de mes muscles apparences
sont des muscles muscles pas des muscles
gonflés je ne sais pas quoi la Grèce de
mes fesses superbe animateur ce soir
alors j'ai affiché un camarade qui avait
fait pipi sur sa chaise bon déjà il est
déjà il est pas propre Géraldine
exprès non non en fait en CP et voilà
donc on travaillait à tout le monde on
devait faire un peu de géo et tout ça
machin bref et la personne devant moi
sacheze commençait à goûter et puis je
me suis dit tiens je vais rien dire sauf
que j'avais une gomme en rond et tout
d'un coup j'ai donné un coup et je vois
la gomme au ralenti qui tombe et qui
roule dans la flaque et donc là du coup
j'ai dit mettre est-ce que je peux
récupérer ma gomme bien sûr récupère ta
gomme il dit oui mais elle est dans la
flaque comment ça la plaque et du coup
on va arriver une grosse flaque et le
petit s'est fait engueuler
comment est-ce que comment est-ce que le
pays
vos cheveux ont changé de couleur non
ils ont juste un peu un peu plus roux
oui parce que
non j'ai fait des shampoings
ça évolue pas se laver les cheveux trop
trop souvent une fois par mois c'est
très bien
une fois tous une fois moi je l'ai fait
une photo les trois mois
vous transpirez du cuir chevelu et vous
vous sentez
aussi pour les cheveux
j'ai enfermé mon directeur dans une
classe pour qu'il fasse la nuit alors ça
peut être soit Daniel pour essayer de
pécho le directeur
ça aurait pu être ça aurait pu être
Raymond Gilles non ça peut très bon ça
c'est quand même proche de l'attentat
c'est moi en fait il m'avait mis 400
lignes je ne dois pas jeter du couscous
sur mes camarades
et j'ai dit mais il m'a fait copier
arrivée à 300 lignes et j'avais fait des
jeux je ne ne dois pas m'a dit tu
recommences tout ça fait 800 non la
parole quand je vais être à l'étude tu
vas morfler j'ai attendu je me suis
caché dans les toilettes jusqu'à 19h il
était tout seul dans son bureau femme de
ménage parti j'ai claqué la porte je
l'ai fermé à double tour
on a passé une semaine cauchemar après
j'imagine mais il a dormi là ils ont dû
lâcher je sais pas quelle heure 22h et
le directeur dans son bureau il y a pas
de téléphone
moi j'ai pas fait l'école en 2012 là
c'est c'est ça fait longtemps que
téléphone c'est depuis 1902 donc dans
les bureaux de classe il y a pas de
téléphone il était directeur mais il
faisait des classes aussi
moi je suis Rambo regarde alors j'ai mis
j'ai mis une balayette à un garçon qui
draguait une fille qui me fait plaisir
toujours dans l'agressivité Gilles à
l'époque je n'avais aucun succès
alors qu'aujourd'hui ça ira tu peux pas
t'aider comme ça
excusez-moi donc du coup il y avait
Bruno ce type mais à chaque fois je l'ai
encore mais c'est une horreur je l'ai
dans la tête encore elle tombait toutes
pour Bruno Bruno depuis le primaire il
me les piquait tout va dans mes rêves et
donc du coup une fois on allait vers la
cantine on descendait au collège Blaise
Pascal de Villemoisson-sur-Orge dans
l'Essonne on descend comme ça il avait
son cartable faut pas le faire c'est
éclater vautré le nez en sang le
cartable répandu comme ça plus aucune
fille n'a voulu de lui le problème c'est
que celle qui me plaisait elle est pas
parti avec moi elle a été avec un autre
lui fini tout toujours un grand galop
voilà alors faut pas le faire
j'ai fait j'ai fait j'avais une prof
d'anglais que j'aimais pas du tout et
j'avais dit je vais remarqué qu'elle
avait une tendance à allumer toujours la
lumière qu'on essaie d'éteindre pour
faire déjà des économies d'énergie et
j'avais mis de l'eau
commentaires non et j'avais bidouillé
l'interrupteur en disant comme ça quand
elle va mettre le
courant à ne pas faire évidemment
c'était l'hiver alors en fait non parce
que comme le bouton est en plastique
mais en revanche ça a fait un énorme
court-circuit tu m'as fait chier pour
les grenades tout à l'heure
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]